Lonestar didn't even see access rangers
whoa dude looking at property on Friday
Wow
I'm with you I'm gonna check it out are
you yeah I keep thinking about I don't I
don't wanna leave the old man behind
don't put me in a Texas corner and make
me bit buy my way out
don't paint don't pay taxes corner nope
okay see what happens let's see what
happens if you want to devastate the
fans in Texas and and firing the kids
you go ahead that's on you buddy
you stay here dude no you don't I live
among the homeless dude I live in Skid
Row I I don't really appreciate being
home with my kids in here ah [ __ ] up
I'll put in my own bud
now [ __ ] oh man I'm just like people
who have mental illness and then need
help I mean I need you to go but in
treatment I need and I don't know if
this helps persuade you you can live on
our property thank you well if you live
in taxi yeah nice full house you live in
the pool house no I have live in my pool
I got my money [ __ ] off okay shut up
I can't I'm gonna do that this weekend
now tell you guys I hurt your eyes I'm
gonna do it like it now um this this but
I'm thinking um if you have an animal I
guess on your property and their house
it's an agro cracks credit so you even
get more money back from the state
already looked at it Papa's gonna have a
sheep and a horse
are you yep I'd love a shoes I'd love
sheep don't need horses too big
I'd like some goats I'd like some
chickens you know I'd like one baby cow
I've asked my friend had a baby cow so
they grow up to be big cows see but I
want that I'll tell you what I can't eat
it
no one's gonna kill him yeah I'm gonna
squirt the milk into my mouth I'm gonna
I'm gonna you know do this a lot I'm
gonna slap him around
i'ma squeeze his nose my kids are gonna
ride him well him Jimmy Ralph yeah if
it's a cow it's his name cows are female
so it's not gonna be a male oh no I'm
Jessie Ralph I met Ralph uh well Ralph
Ralph inna afina oh dude oh my god I'm
[ __ ] with you dude I oh my god
[ __ ] with you dude I'm gonna get a
long horn in Texas farm I'm gonna a
giant more i safe around kids now here's
the thing
security yeah the joints up on the
property but my boy over here Bruce yeah
I'll [ __ ] you up now
well there's stories about fighting
bulls in Spain that cut out and got into
houses and killed people in their own
houses see I don't want that I don't
really bring up Madeira fighting ball
oh yeah that's brutal dude take a look
at these another fine oh that's brutal
oh you're not allowed to approach them
on foot on foot in Spain by law because
otherwise you will get chin do me of I
don't like seeing that do me a favor I
don't want to you speaking of cookies
and animals yeah I can't I I don't think
I'm gonna eat pig anymore I just read
all these are so smart smartened dog but
they're also like they have the
cognitive cognition of a three-year-old
human [ __ ] I don't think I can do it no
I read that I was like I like the word
like a port chania I live work I live
before I don't I hate pork but the way
they keep them in these crates I don't
think I can do it I like ribs now it's a
wild risk if it's a wild pig and I got
props on my boars we're gonna shut those
down and I gotta shut them down um chin
see how much of Texas Longhorn cos
goodbye
that's gonna be my security guard my
kids are gonna grow up with it okay
we're gonna we're gonna file down this
warrants okay he's gonna be head of
security it seems me Bruce Bruce yeah
statue sighs that bull I'm [ __ ] our
balls dude mm-hmm
how much is a miniature long one okay
we're looking about okay
see that big one on the right that's
what I'm looking for but he's too old
not for sale says not this 2500 look at
the little bull now you get yourself a
bull for 25 I'm in oh uh well 20 oh my
god Anabelle point hey let me see boot
it up down below there boot it up 5,200
yeah like little heifer Oh tada I like
the the cut-and-dried heifer for 1,700
that's how it says cut and dried heifer
yeah that's the deal from our patch I'm
cutting drives name's gonna be Brucie
we're home a little bruised cutie pie
any cute so I'm gonna move to Texas I'm
gonna buy little Bruce I'm jealous now
what I want to know is the maintenance
on those things it's price maintenance
gotta have it you got to have a cowhand
around and this is why I want you Kim
Texas where you watch my mic longer I'm
a man I'm a man I'm a man among I'll pay
you
I'm a beast master yes take care of my
longboard yeah I con will get tough
checks whoa cowboy tough check forget
dirty dancer 3,300 what do you some jazz
records objects isn't for sale
he's my boy hot red cone is though or
door jam 3200 damn what are dragging
blaze drag honor y'all a drag Ella
oh my god dragon smile Dropbox dude look
at the possibilities how about I get a
nice drop to ace with a easy whip five
grand I get my security I like that
I'm feeling froggy by Olga foe of goth
oh well I'd like I'm gonna get myself no
cows and no horses I'm gonna get myself
some goats I'll get myself some chickens
a little couple oh I'm absent I some
dogs chickens not some dogs that keep
the coats or the sheep yeah you know
karate I look at this property three
acres your [ __ ] animals roam around
kids who a fool imma kick ball need to
come papa
Oh God I need you come come I'm coming
I'll be there no state tax Jesus Christ
save some mone save some when you stand
up out there do the road Lelia chin
foaming-at-the-mouth don't want to come
look at cat
you both come I'm from Texas so that's
why I have like a love for Texas boy
that's a big move that's a tough one
yeah but you consider it for sure
cat hmm I'm thinking about it but I'm
leaning more towards yeah but they're
gonna say no like no I quit today
all right bye guys look at that hole
talk to the father-in-law father-in-law
my gram yeah mother oh so down
everyone's excited it's pretty good
Davis let's see we can stay here and
have never knew somebody your daddy and
taxes going
on this one what taxes don't help all my
stuff hmm how interesting
I don't know I'm just could you take
Adam Newsome and I just wanted to be oh
I know yeah right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]